ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre le hashtag prisonnière
du hidjab fleurissent sur les réseaux
sociaux de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée derrière il y à des femmes
courageuses qui dénonce le voile comme
un instrument d'oppression
elle pointe du doigt la pression sociale
et l'environnement familial qui les
condamne à se voiler
chez nous aussi la pression des
quartiers et des familles ne l'est en
réalité que peu de choix aux femmes
voilées en particulier aux plus jeunes
d'entre elles alors que les femmes
algériennes nous indique la voie du
courage
la position de votre majorité est sur ce
sujet d'une ambiguïté problématique
or la france nation des droits de
l'homme doit véhiculer un message de
liberté pour les femmes du monde entier
le président de la république le 16
avril 2018 déclaré que le voile n'était
pas conforme à la civilité qu'il ya dans
notre pays le 28 février dernier il se
muer en défenseur du voile expliquant
que les entreprises qui discriminent les
femmes voilées al embauche devait être
sévèrement sanctionnés sur ce sujet
l'exécutif est donc preuve d'angélisme
pire de contradictions pouvez-vous au
nom du gouvernement devant notre
assemblée condamné à nouveau les propos
d'un député de votre majorité qui a
réalisé la semaine dernière un amalgame
surréaliste entre le port du hidjab et
celui du serre tête alors que ce célèbre
demain la journée de la femme il est
essentiel de rappeler que le combat pour
une véritable égalité homme femme passe
aussi par le combat sur notre territoire
de toute forme de fondamentalisme dont
le voile est souvent un étendard
monsieur le premier ministre
le voile est il oui ou non un instrument
d'oppression des femmes et que comptez
vous faire pour protéger toutes ces
femmes qui sur le territoire français
sont contraintes de le porter je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice
je rappellerai simplement que nous
sommes dans un pays où la laïcité est la
règle et la laïcité s'inscrit au fronton
de toutes nos mairies et au fronton de
toutes nos institutions
je crois que nous devons respecter
également la volonté de chacun de porter
ou non les attributs vestimentaires
qu'il souhaite porter dans l'espace
public
je dis bien dans l'espace public
pour le reste moi je préférerais que
nous nous dirigions vers ce que nous
mettons en oeuvre au niveau de ce
gouvernement c'est à dire une vraie
diplomatie féministe afin que nous
puissions partager nos convictions avec
de façon universelle sur les violences
faites aux femmes sur les contraintes
faites aux femmes sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes sur
l'émancipation des femmes qui sont des
concepts qui à notre sens doivent être
des concepts universels et qui nécessite
l'engagement de toutes et tous
je crois sur le plan national et sur le
plan international
et c'est dans ce sens que marlène
schiappa de travail
c'est dans ce sens également que le
président de la république remettra le
prix simone veil qui récompense les
actions en faveur des droits des femmes
dans le monde et c'est dans ce sens
également que sera travaillé au niveau
de la présidence du g7 l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes parce que ce
dont vous me parlez madame c'est une
question d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et pour nous cela est
absolument essentiel
mais je le rappelle cela doit s'inscrire
dans notre pays dans un esprit de
laïcité qui est la règle en france dans
notre république française
merci madame boulet espérons y est pour
quelques petites secondes
madame la ministre je prends acte de
votre réponse j'ai bien peur qu'elle
soit en total décalage avec le sens de
mon message
vous devez vous devez réaffirmer les
valeurs d'universalisme qui font l'adn
de la france vous devez nommer les
problèmes pour mieux les combattre et le
relativisme qui fait l'apanage de votre
gouvernance depuis le départ est une
mauvaise réponse à de vrais problèmes je
vous demande d'y réfléchir
il est temps il est temps vraiment
[Applaudissements]